what's the first thing you would do when
you look in your bank account
and it has a billion dollars
smile
[Music]
yo this future and I'm about to answer
some GQ celebrity questions
[Music]
future what up man
my question to you is
what are moments of self-doubt like for
you
and how often do you experience them
uh self-doubt
oh no [ __ ] down there every day
of like
just making sure you're achieving
everything you want to do and just stand
on top of everything and not knowing
it's like
we're making sure you just get the most
out of everything around you everyone
around you it's like
so it might not be the self-doubt it
might be someone else doubting me or
someone around me might not feel like
they're 100 sure what I'm doing that's
the thing that I have to do every day I
feel like I have to uh
constantly no matter how much success
you have you got to continue to prove
yourself every day
[Music]
your future bless up it's your brother
cattley you know what I'm saying since
your name is the great future what's the
future looking like tell me tell us all
talk to me man how we looking out there
what's the future saying from future
love you brother how the future is
looking billions
this is looking office builders
real estate companies publishing
companies just assess all around
whatever I put my mind to
whatever that is like in the future
whatever I'm putting my mind to
want to be successful and reach His
Highest Potential
[Music]
hi future
do you want more kids
um yes
by my wife if I ever get married you
know say I want to have kids but my wife
of course
it could be like three because I never
had more than one kid about a girl so
like if I had two bars and it's like
more than I had so I feel like it was
more special
[Music]
future what's up bro got a question for
you if you could pay one artist past or
present female or male to do a joint
album with who would it be
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
um
should we in Houston
I just said it wasn't here because the
first thing probably my one of my
favorite songs uh I'll Always Love You
that's my favorite song artists like
I love the song over the voice so you
don't have to be 10 songs it could be
six songs I don't know
but Whitney Houston
how does it feel this is for future
how does it feel
proving yourself right and every doubt
[ __ ] wrong
best of luck on all your endeavors
brother very proud
I feel good
[Music]
move I guess
myself right into
the road it's a great feeling
do you ever read
like negative comments on the internet
do you read any comments
no
no
you know you're popular
I guess so
it's cool to me because I guess it's
something cool to be that why you don't
have to read it
yo it's for Luigi uh we're in beautiful
Switzerland
and my brother Pluto I wanted to ask you
if you were stuck in an island what are
three things you can't live without and
you can't say rude
[Music]
uh
can't live without water
um
on the island I'm supposed to weed
and oh we gotta have a girl with me
[Music]
so I know you're taking all these other
questions and like
whatever right
um I just got a question for you man I
just want to pick a bone with you uh I'm
gonna be straight up about it are you
coming with my man uh uh um like I feel
like you're talking to my girl
she keep texting somebody and and it
keep popping up as like the Pluto emoji
and then she I'm like she's an anatomy
major in school so I haven't like really
said too much to her about it but I'm
gonna just be I'm a man at first you
know what I'm saying I'm a man first so
I'm Gonna Be A Man About It about the
situation and I'm gonna go ahead and
address it are you [ __ ] with her bro
and I mean it is what it is uh I charge
it to the game man
we need a picture of her
yeah cause I don't even know her name so
I got to see the face you know how these
women is these days you never know
you never know that's the beauty of it
but the thing is she's still here so
is there anything
[Music]
[ __ ] I can't erase the past
that's something I can't do
that's it GQ peace
[Music]